climbed up now I'm on
hello, good afternoon, it's now 2 o'clock, I
think we'll wait a very short
moment, it's quite a long
way here from the street,
probably one or the
other will still need a minute for the
two of them to
climb the stairs  In
ten minutes it can still
get here but
I do
n't see anyone else on the way.
I would say we start then.
My name is Marcel Rich and my topic
is green hydrogen, that is the gas
of the future.
Before I start I will  Briefly introduce myself,
I was born in 1982. Why
I'm telling you this will become
clear in the following slides. I got
a bachelor's degree in physics
in Darmstadt and then
went to Canada for a semester abroad after doing it myself.
I can't show it here, but that's on  on the
right side of my slide
there in North America then I
got a master's degree and
then I went back to
Germany to Berlin to the Free
University again on the left side
of my slide
then I went hello across the
Atlantic
to the USA to Boston or  Cambridge to
myt Massachusetts Institute of
Technology from there then to Göttingen
and from Göttingen I
ended up here in Berlin.
Today I am a junior research group leader at the
Helmholtz Center Berlin and still a
guest at the University of Göttingen and as I
already mentioned last year my
research interests and  My topic
is green hydrogen, what exactly is it?
If you don't know that yet,
I'll explain it in the next few slides,
from my personal world map to
this very beautiful NASA world map
at night. I hope you can
see that even when there are lights  It seems to be in very good condition,
you can see a lot of individual bright
colored dots here, most of which are
not evenly distributed over the
earth, but most of them can be
seen in North America, in Europe, in
India, you can see many in Asia, China
along the Nile, and you can see them very
clearly
That shows us where we have enough
energy to light up the earth at night.
Unfortunately, about 80% of this
energy comes from fossil sources
and the rest has to be
stored for energy and that is also the topic today
back to the
use of fossil energies  Fossil fuels had a
pretty big influence and has a
pretty big influence on our earth
here is what is shown Temperature increase
between 1970 and
around 2018 should be with an
extra polished trend line I
also told you that when I was born in
1982 what you see here is during  in
my lifetime, it's not
like the dinosaurs that are out there,
it's really happening right now and it
also happened during my life when I was
growing up all the time and the
trend and fortunately continues
upwards
now higher temperature has but also a
variety of other effects on the
Earth one of these possible effects there
are really a lot of it
shown here that there is a Google app you can
look at is called Earth Engine
and it shows here the Columbia
Glacier in Alaska from
1984 until the 2000s that is
now moving pretty slowly  So in
the 1990s there isn't much happening, you
see a little more than there, sometimes there is
a little less than there and at
some point in the 2000s all of a sudden everything
is happening pretty much the same
now it's very thin and all of a sudden it's
gone,
all of these processes don't work
exactly linearly from that oscillates a
little hotter comes
here again or something was probably quite cold in 2009
but on average this
glacier tongue has now disappeared, unfortunately
due to the use of fossil fuels and
the increase in global temperature
and as I said, that is also like this
temperature increase in  It's happened in my lifetime, so it's
no surprise that the UN has defined 17
very important sustainability goals
and one of these
goals is affordable and clean energy,
that should also be the topic here
The important thing
now we'll be a little more precise about
why we need energy in
Germany. There
are so-called sectors here.
Firstly, there is transport, which consumes
around 27% of the total energy.
Then I'll go around clockwise,
then there is industry, which
consumes around 27%  28%
then there are the households that's
all of us probably we need 28
also about 28%
and last but not least there are
commercial trade and services with
about 15 16 percent
in total this makes up 2333 terawatt hours if you
look at it as a cake
terawatt hours
are a billion kilowatt hours and
you can perhaps use your own
electricity consumption at home so an
average three person
household in Germany has
used around 2500 so that's
almost the equivalent of almost a
billion three person households that's how much
energy we use in Germany
and that's a lot
and  Of course, we want to
continue to use this energy in order to
maintain our standard of living.
Here I have broken it down again
and where does this energy come from
at the moment? As I said, that is now the
total energy again, which is also with
heating
fuel, so that you fill up the car with,
for example  with and on electricity
here you will now notice and
a few things will certainly become clear to you.
Natural gas made up
26.8% of this in 2021.
Over a quarter of our entire huge energy consumer is covered
or was
covered by natural gas,
so certainly a quarter  The topic for
another lecture, but I don't want to go into it any further now,
if we now look at electricity generation,
we can see that it looks a
little different.
Here I have summarized the individual sources a
little more,
we are now just looking at the right side  On the
electricity side,
we have around 40 percent from
fossil sources and
almost 46% from renewable sources and
then we have the sliver of
energy, so when it comes to electricity we
already generate a lot from renewable sources,
I'll show you what influence that has
right now on the  Next slide
here you can see the electricity generation and
electricity consumption around November 5th
last year,
the data from today was
not yet available,
we can now see different gangs
running here, the labels are
probably too small unless you are
really sitting at the front in red  and then
we have nuclear energy then we have
various water storage systems in blue then
we have biomass in green and brown,
various types of coal are shown
in orange natural gas and the renewables I'll
now limit myself to wind
and solar which are wind is in
[music]
a light shade of green  shown and solar
is shown in yellow
so that's how the electricity generation was made
up last year this week
and in black I hope it's thick
enough to see that was the consumption you can
already see here that was
n't quite right sometimes last year
either  you have to buy a little bit
or add some from other sources
while towards the end of the week
last year
the sun seemed to be shining very well
and it was also quite
windy as you can see in this graph,
we produced a lot from renewable
energies that was then  just
handed over, ideally sold or
just handed over to other countries,
what would happen if we
said tomorrow we don't want to
have any more fossil sources, only
the renewable ones,
that's what will happen here, I
just
switched off all fossil and nuclear power,
you can see it fits  Now it's not quite enough
for consumption
so we have to do something. You could
say now that we're just installing
a few more, I'll
just double the amount of
installed wind power plants and
solar power plants.
Unfortunately, that still doesn't quite fit
and you can already see it  in the
original data
if we rely more on renewable energies
we have to store energy we
have to store energy very efficiently
so that it is available to us
when we need it because we will
we were here also sees on my
some days we will
produce a lot and there  We then store
it for other days when we need it
because the wind isn't blowing that way or
because the sun isn't shining enough.
You can store energy using
different media. I would like to limit myself
here to chemical
energy storage. One type
of chemical energy storage is in
batteries  You may know them from
the household, this shouldn't
be an issue here, it's certainly very
important for the energy transition, but here
it should only be about
storage in chemical fuels,
especially green hydrogen
as a fuel
Page
from bottom to top through green
hydrogen is what we want,
CO2 is produced from water using
electrolysis, so
no further CO2 is produced during production
then there is the so-called blue
hydrogen, CO2 is produced but it
is neutralized in some way or another
compensated
and then there is the gray hydrogen,
which also produces
CO2. Nowadays, if they are good somewhere, it
is relatively difficult to buy hydrogen,
but if you were to do that,
it predominantly comes from the gray
sources, i.e. from fossil sources, so they
have by-products, for example  Because
petroleum then natural gas production,
as I said, this is about green
hydrogen, which is produced free of CO2
using a process
called electrolysis.
Maybe you have already seen this process or
this experiment in school.
You had your slap pipe
in this experiment that you fill  With
water you put two electrons into
the electrodes, you then
connect a current, ideally from
renewable energy,
and then you see that
gases develop on the two electrodes, hydrogen develops on the
negative electrode
and oxygen develops on the positive
electrode
I'm going to go into a little
more detail now, a little
chemically, so here I'm going to
go through this slide from left to right. At the
beginning we have the water. Water is
H2O and we want to split that up.
Then we make an oxygen molecule out of the split
water.
We also get o2  four electrons
and we get four charged
hydrogen particles.
These four charged hydrogen particles
then move through our
liquid to the other electrode
and the electrons run through
the outside of the circuit
but from the other electrode we
then do what we want, namely
green hydrogen H2 to be precise
Two water makes two
hydrogen.
This green hydrogen can then be
used as fuel, for example
to power trains or trucks,
and my colleagues also have a
model car here, so I'll come
back to it later and say where
they did the experiment  or where you can take a look at his
hydrogen-powered vehicle
so we have the water then
we apply a voltage and from there
we generate the charged
hydrogen particles. This is deliberately said
because in addition to green hydrogen you can
also use it to produce many very important other
chemicals
For example, a nitrogen
reacts on it and gets ammonia, which
is the basis for fertilizer
or ammonia can also be
used as fuel. The federal government
also, I believe, negotiated a deal with Qatar
that we get ammonia from
Qatar.
You can also use these charged hydrogen
particles  react on carbon atoms,
this is just one
example, there are an incredible number of
reactions and an incredible number of very,
very important molecules that we make.
If you have hydrogen and carbon,
maybe a little bit of oxygen,
you can produce a lot of very
important materials, starting
materials for them  chemical
industry raw materials for medicines
also this
charged hydrogen that
can be obtained from electrolysis is not
only an important fuel with green hydrogen itself
but also a
very important raw material for the
future supply of materials
with medicines for food in
the agricultural sector and  In the
energy sector
today, most of these
processes are also based on
fossil raw materials, as I said, you can
also do this via electrolysis with
renewables using water and other
substances.
So after so much chemistry, I would like to
wake you all up again and have
prepared a little quiz for you  When do
you think this was invented? Water was
split into hydrogen and
oxygen
so who thinks water splitting this
process that I just described
was invented a few billion years ago
because a show of hands here a few
people are very careful is quite long
we have say ten people today
maybe who thinks in about
that  are a few more yes who thinks in
1985 one person two people are
brave good then a third person
good then we come to the resolution so
about 2.7 to 3.8 billion
years ago nature invented water splitting
that's the one  Process that
takes place in photosynthesis in
photosynthesis the product is a
little different but basically it is the
same reaction that you split the water
and create something great with the charged
hydrogen particles
in this case in
photosynthesis the great thing is all kinds of
biomass for example  The wooden chairs
sit straight on the lake and were also
created at some point through this process.
In 1789, an experiment took place in the
Netherlands by Pets von
Draiswick and Deimann and they then
split water in a similar way to what they
showed you in the animation before  such a U-shaped
vessel and applied a voltage to it. The
topic of applying voltage was
pretty high-tech back then, so you
can. At that time there was no power supply,
no socket. The possibility for
these researchers to apply the voltage
is shown here in these paintings. This
is an electro-state generator  and
you can see that, like today,
large-scale equipment research is
very, very complex to
have electricity in order to then use it to produce hydrogen.
Unfortunately, the year 1985 was the only
wrong answer, but there was
also a very important invention there
The lithium-ion battery was
invented and the first
prototype of the lithium-ion battery was
presented.
However, this is less about
the process in nature and
I will
come back to it briefly later and more about the
technical process
Let's now move forward 233 years to the
year 2022.
This is just part 2 of my
imagination. These are selected questions
that concern me in my research,
namely how does
water splitting work on the atomic level,
which atoms do we need? Which
environment of the atoms is particularly
important which atoms  themselves are
particularly important, which properties
they must have are not yet
fully understood, but a better
understanding of this would allow us
to design better catalysts in a more targeted manner.
I will come back to that point in a
moment. In particular, it is interesting which materials currently determine the durability of the electrodes  Electrodes are mostly
made from precious metals, which makes them
very durable but also very expensive.
Money is a problem, the much
bigger problem is that we simply
don't have enough precious metals on
earth to realize this on the scale
that we
need it  We use other materials and
these other materials
also work, but unfortunately they are less
durable than the precious metal references
we have.
Then there is
the efficiency of hydrogen production, which
is not yet optimal, especially the
production of charged
hydrogen particles.
A lot of energy is currently being lost  and you
have precious metals or not, it's the
same for all materials in this
process, unfortunately and there is also a
lot of research effort
to improve efficiency,
so the question is still which
cheap and
available materials are
particularly suitable for
hydrogen production
here  Now a current example from
our research
where we made an electrode and
applied a material to an electrode for this reaction that was
initially crystalline as you can see on the
right and looked like
individual needles were such elongated
crystals that is what
we used  We let these materials
split water for a
very long time
and through this process they
changed. That's also something
you need to know.
Most of the materials
we use change over
time.
Most materials get
worse and could do that  So from the
household, I don't know what we can think of at the moment,
any tires or all the
other technical devices that we
have. The longer you use them, the
worse they become at some point,
they don't work that much anymore, it's the
same here, but not with
our material  better over
time
it has changed from these
crystalline needles to an
amorphous structure that means it was
structure what he and defined and became
porous like his Swiss cheese
these properties then over
time an
electrocatal or a material he
shows that something worked more efficiently
than  Before then
it ripened just like this cheese
or like a good wine while it
was in operation
then I have already
told you that the material improves
through use and our
insights
show how which material is what
you have to change in the material
lasts longer or maybe even
gets better with use over time
how do we get to know exactly what these
properties are?
We need a modern
large-scale research device, a so-called
syncrotron, which here shows the Berlin
electron storage ring or Berlin
electron storage synchrotron Messi, which
is already better 2 to C1  was at
Breitscheidplatz this one is now at
Adlershof a nice photo at night
is the round huge structure in the
middle for comparison you can
see the street there, I think it's the street here on the
right side and I do
n't remember exactly what the main street is  Since
Adlershof is called and it is located
in its synchronous state, electrons are
accelerated to close to the speed of light
and they are forced into a circular path
and this means that radiation has to be
given off and we can try to use this radiation to
better understand our materials, a kind of very
intense X-ray light source  they
built there
and with this X-ray we can
make the material visible on the atomic level just like this superhero
here and Superman
can see through things with an X-ray vision.
This gentleman calls himself exas my access
is a technical term for the method
to do this  It looks
at the material and then sees which atoms
are in it and how these
atoms are arranged - very valuable
information if you want to understand
how materials work or how
these materials are structured on an atomic level,
as I said, that's an order of
magnitude that you can't  You ca
n't see them with the eye, but
you can make them visible with the eye.
We shoot our light at the sample.
Some of these samples are also
under operating conditions.
This gives us insights into the
chemical state, which atoms they are,
how many electrons they have in the
outer shell  This is called the
oxidation number and what is its atomic
structure, how are the individual
atoms located relative to each other?
If you are more interested in
how this fantastic
light source, the X-ray light source,
works, there will be an
online lecture next Thursday
from 1 to 2 p.m.
think about it  You can then use the program on the
website to
find out the corresponding lecture.
Feel free to take a photo,
but what do we do with these
insights? We now have a
modern research device and can
make atoms visible in some way and better understand what
properties they have and
what they are about  I think
it's shown below between the triangle,
we have the hydrogen on an
electrode of an electrode material and
that goes into a bond
with it,
this bond can either be too strong
then we don't get any hydrogen
because let's just say the
hydrogen  sticks to the electrode
or the bond is too weak
then we don't get any hydrogen
because the hydrogen does
n't get to the electrode at all and can't
react any further.
To understand this better, you plot
a material property of the electrode
against the hydrogen production,
which already does  said then there are
options where you
choose material properties that the
bond is too strong or the bond
is too weak and then there is a very
special point up there in the greens
perfect it is neither too strong nor too
weak and that's where you do with this  At this
point you want the materials or
you want to get the materials to this point
so the question is which knob do
we have to turn and understand materials better
and from the bonds that are too strong to the
bonds that are too weak but
ideally to end up with an ideal bond is
a possible material property
I had already mentioned
that the number of external electrons that is suitable for this is the number of outer electrons,
which you could
plot down there and then the
hydrogen production and there you would
find certain values ​​at which
the hydrogen production is optimal and
then the challenge is now
to set up a laboratory and then produce this material
or you have already produced it then
you have now finally understood why
it is much better than all the other
materials that you have previously produced
so from a very small microscopic
view it is now a little larger again
in the distant future, what I
told you,
no, that's not it either and
the production of green hydrogen
is also technically implemented and is
not that far away from here, for example
in Prenzlau there is a hybrid power plant
there are three wind turbines coupled to an
electrolysis system and the
performance figures are there  Because it's
a little bigger than trying to do it in the laboratory,
so you can do it today and
no further research really had to be done.
This
hybrid power plant in Prenzlauer was
built entirely on existing technologies that
were combined together. If I remember correctly, that
would be the case  It was
completed in 2011 and was the world's
first hybrid power plant that
works with hydrogen,
so the production of green
hydrogen is not science fiction;
you can do it and
do it right near
Berlin, but it is a
pilot power plant and it is not
widespread  everywhere in Germany
or in the cosmopolitan city
you could ask why is this so,
perhaps because generation with
wind power is too expensive or
generation with
photovoltaics with solar is too expensive,
but that is not the case, what I have
shown here are the costs of generating
electricity  is operation and
purchase in 2021 in June,
different variants of photovoltaics are shown here in yellow,
generating kilowatt hours costs
between three and at the top almost 20
euro cents per kilowatt hour. Wind is
shown in blue, generating costs
between four and around 12
each  depending on whether you do it on land
or offshore i.e. on the sea then
we also have biogas in green which
is between 8 and 17 euro cents.
Here the fossil ones are also shown
which are more expensive here than the
renewable ones or let's say they
catch them  If yes, you have a listener, the basic costs
are for systems that you would build new.
Nowadays,
appropriate certificates
have to be purchased,
but if you
want to expand the energy supply,
renewables are available these days and are not too expensive. I
have also drawn a black line here, which
is the price of electricity at the moment  Unfortunately a bit
expensive when I produced it, the
last data showed that the
average price was around 37 cents per
kilowatt hour end consumer price,
around a quarter of this price is
for electricity generation, which is around 9%
and that is the line so
you can go with renewables
Photovoltaics and also with wind
produce electricity more cheaply in order to
generate or get cheaper electricity prices again.
As I said, this is now the case for
electricity generation in Germany. If we
now take a quick look at photovoltaics,
that is the best or photovoltaics
is already very good in Germany  But
if you do it differently
here in the regions shown in red there will
be even more solar energy there
you can produce even more electricity with
photovoltaics, for example,
why I'm telling you that if you
wanted to do that and make this electricity usable again in
Germany  then
we have to store energy again and
a very good way to do that, as
I have already said several times, is
to then generate hydrogen from it
and transport this hydrogen.
Then unfortunately there are
costs again. Here is data shown from 2019,
which we have in gray  the gray
hydrogen, what does it cost to
produce one kilowatt hour or a
kilowatt equivalent of
blue hydrogen and the green
hydrogen that we want to have here,
these are unfortunately
still very expensive renewable energies,
but the predictions are that
these prices will go down significantly
here in this study  Something like
ten cents per kilowatt hour would
go down, that generation
would only cost 6 cents
and this cost reduction must be
achieved through research. These are
things that are not understood, these are the questions
that concern me: how can you
make it more durable, how can you
make it more efficient and that  makes it
cheaper at the end of the day,
like 6 cents if we go back,
let's think the photovoltaics are
14 at best,
for storage we're around 10
cents, well the distribution will also
cost a bit, probably
10 cents then the kilowatt hour of electricity would be
20  its costs and then it will
probably also
be taxed. I don't have a simple answer
but let's see how much it will be.
What else can you do with the
hydrogen that you then
produce? Here is a study from the
FAZ for a self-sufficient house
in  This self-sufficient house on the
right has an electrolyser
that produces the hydrogen, stores
the hydrogen and this can then be
used again in a fuel cell.
What comes out of the fuel cell
can be used, for example, to
use electricity in the household, you can heat,
produce hot water
Everything is green and should be self-sufficient.
Ideally, the electricity for
the electrolyzer comes from a
photovoltaic module, which you
often see on roofs these days, and is
then stored in a battery.
Something like that is not very common,
but it's not science fiction
like that either  There are also concept houses in
Germany, but in other countries it is
a bit more widespread. I
once met a colleague from Japan at a specialist conference on the
topic of fuel cells
and he
said yes, he also has a
fuel cell generator in the house to
maintain the power supply
or as  Emergency power,
yes, is a generator, so that's been
quite common for a few years now
in Japan where there is also the
appropriate infrastructure for
hydrogen. If you
want to take a look at a hydrogen car, you can
do that here today too. UPS
Museum, over there again there is a stand
my colleagues from Kettler and HZB
there are big hydrogen cars
small hydrogen cars toy cars
the stand is called Earth 11
as my little son says and that
's behind the big dinosaurs so you
can't miss it once you've found the big
dinosaurs just
keep walking  and then on the right
side you can take
a closer look at
this demonstration car here
and there is the
corresponding solar cell that you would
connect to this device
and then first of all one over this
blue box here that operates as an electrolyzer
some hydrogen
then make the power connection, change the connection,
unplug the solar cell and then
use the hydrogen generated there so that
this toy car moves, it
really works and as I said you
can look at it afterwards.
I saved myself the attempt to
set up
the lecture hall here
suitable for experiments there is already
a question or
yes the well-known question about the
efficiency because only 30 percent can then be
used for transportation,
unlike the
electric car that can then convert 70% with electricity
we are there the
research perspectives can
then the efficiency  can be increased significantly,
how do you see that,
thank you, that it
can be increased significantly, but I
deliberately did not show a hydrogen car at the beginning in the course of the other
slide,
but rather a hydrogen train and also
mentioned the hydrogen truck. I think
for these larger devices one will
I think using hydrogen in
cars if you look at how much
VW BMW Mercedes are currently investing in
battery technology and how
much they are investing in
hydrogen technology then you can
make up your own mind. It's a good question
and I really think you could
do it even better, you will  also do
better but you
probably won't see any
four-seater hydrogen cars. You
can sell the Toyota a number of times
if Toyota sells it to you,
but
then it also has the problem that
you can't really fill it up in
Berlin, but probably not
if you use it  the highway drives
and the efficiency I don't have the foils
here,
but I also show that in my lecture.
I only have a prototype from
an American laboratory
and the overall efficiency was
better than the combustion engine with it, which is
a normal combustion engine but
I think it really
depends on the details. I
now have a few more slides and
since that will also be recorded if
you can still remember the questions,
I would like to answer you at the end
and finish my three and four slides
I really wanted you to
be so interested in it
and can you then ask these questions at the end
I hope that's okay, well
here I had planned to take
another look at
photosynthesis Photo synthesis is produced in
green leaves and also in green algae
and as I have already
mentioned, photosynthesis has
produced all the biomass on earth, i.e. all the wood they
sit on and all fossil fuels
were produced at some point through
food synthesis, so a very
important process and a very ingenious,
simple process, you have a kind
chemical reactor in the plant - the
plants in sunlight take CO2
from the air and also water and
produce a lot of useful chemicals from them.
What I have shown you so far was that
existing technologies can be
combined, i.e. an electrolyzer which
then splits the water into its
components  with photovoltaics with
wind power but something in the distant
future that does
n't exist yet is artificial photosynthesis
for me it would be that you directly
build a device that replicates the functions of the
plant where
the fuels and
chemicals come out directly through solar energy  There
's a
[music] about it,
so that's an active field of research
and I wanted to mention that
it can also go in this direction, that
it can be developed even further and that we
get closer to where the plants go,
but that only makes sense if this
development takes place  Efficiency improves the whole
process
Another advantage here, as with the
self-sufficient house, would be that it is decentralized
every plant does this independently of
the one next to it,
so we come to the conclusion that green
hydrogen is an attractive pressure
fuel but also a raw material for many
other important processes such as
electrolysis  has been known since the 18th
century and the production
of green hydrogen is already
technically possible today, but the efficiency
still needs to be further improved and
currently
we are still using
very expensive and rare materials in these devices where it is technically possible, so
further research is needed
take place in order to improve
the basic processes are
not yet fully understood and further
research is important and urgently needed
so that these materials
can be improved in a knowledge-based and very targeted manner. In
particular, one would like to
improve efficiency, which is already mentioned in the question. I
suspect there will be
more to come  Questions come and longevity.
No one wants to develop a material
that only lasts a day. It should
last dangerously for 30 years.
Large-scale use of hydrogen is
possible, but it requires
a bit of rethinking in the implementation.
I have touched on a few points about this. A
few points may still come into play
Questions the most important point here with
what is important in rethinking is my
point we have to store energy
more renewable energies will not
work if we do not
have better options or if we have
energy if we cannot store this energy
for the days when
the renewables  Sources are not available.
Finally, a brief outlook. There
is a study from 2017
that 100% renewable energies are possible worldwide.
This study looks at what
effects this has on
society. They come to the
conclusion that it does create jobs  or
jobs will be lost, but
globally around twice as many will be created
as will be lost. There is
a lot of information in there. I
broke it down to three points that were important to me.
In 2050, it is predicted that the
switch to 100% renewable energy will cost
$22,800 billion in
air pollution  saves,
for comparison, German
reunification cost around
1,000 to 2,000 billion US dollars,
so an incredibly large sum of a
similar magnitude, even a
little larger at
28,500 billion US dollars
per year for climate change, which
you wouldn't have as a result, of course
it will  It costs a lot of money
to implement the whole thing, but as I said, it is
already technically possible and this
study comes to the conclusion that it is also
possible with the existing materials. The
last point is also particularly
important to me if you no longer have any costs for
fossil fuels
In principle,
energy prices are also stable and no longer
depend on the fact that you have to buy oil or gas somewhere,
but you are only
dependent on the sun shining
and the wind blowing and you know
statistically how much that is and how
much you have to store to get through
winter is coming or that you can get through the
day
so that's the end of the lecture,
thank you very much, I've already seen it, there
are a few questions that I'll be
happy to answer afterwards
[applause]
yes, first of all, thank you very much for
this informative lecture  The question
relates to the topic of research,
international research on green
hydrogen, you mentioned the
Japanese colleague you met a few years ago. There is a
lot of transparency when researching it together, or is there such
a competition? What is the
exchange of research like?  When can
you expect better results?
Yes, very good question. Science is very
international and there is also a
lot of exchange on the subject of artificial
photosynthesis. For example, during
my doctorate I was marginally involved in an
EU research project. There were a
lot of countries from the  European Union
have come together to do more research on the
topic of artificial photosynthesis and
its aspects.
At the moment I know that
some researchers in Germany and the
USA are working very closely together on the
topic of artificial photosynthesis and
improving these processes.
There are often calls for tenders for
international ones  work together
so my answer to that is it's very
international
personally I think you could and
have to make it a little more international
unfortunately you don't hear as much about other countries as you do about others
and now the
corona restrictions have changed in the
last two years
I can't tell you what happened internationally
because there were no conferences where
people could exchange ideas, but in the
long term, yes, that answered the first
question. There was
another part of the question, a
really very interesting lecture. I
wanted to add it again  say that
artificial photosynthesis has already been
developed here at the
ETH stand, screws made of
titanium dioxide have somehow been developed to
imitate artificial photosynthesis naturally and then with very poor efficiency, yes
and my one question then counts again
this house of the FAZ how would they
Hydrogen storage has to be
compressed again or is it
simply under ambient pressure? The tanks are
how are they going to say what
energy densities are there?
Unfortunately, from the technical level I don't have any data on this. The graphic would
now suggest that it is as
hydrogen gas in the pressure  storage
is stored
but what I would like to comment on
is that it
is also an open scientific question
as to how to
store hydrogen most efficiently and how to keep the
hydrogen in the storage medium
because it is so small
and therefore very volatile  You can
store it in a pressure vessel if
you perhaps
know it from your household and want to make your own sparkling water for these gas soda makers.
You can also get hydrogen in a similar way
if you order it for
research purposes or you can then
bind it to other solids, for example
but what  was now used here
and how efficient the whole thing is then
unfortunately there is no comment on the
subject of artificial photosynthesis. Yes, there is
a lot of research, a lot of
demonstration projects as far as
I know and I would be happy to be
corrected, nothing comparable to
this power plant there in Prenzlauer where you can do
that  on a larger in a larger
technical system but
maybe that's not where
it's going to go but
I don't know if she could hear that,
so a prototype of an
artificial photosynthesis that then
produces carbon-containing products
can also be found behind these
dinosaurs  At the etc stand
you can also build it,
yes, it's my turn, thank you very much for the
nice lecture. What I understood
and what everyone understood is
of course that we need electricity to
produce hydrogen and that of
course has to be green electricity and in
this context  The question
is about efficiency and you don't have that,
so I would ask you to
perhaps give a number, how
many watts of electricity do I need to
produce an equivalent of hydrogen,
which provides me with one watt as fuel,
that would
interest me because you have to  Even
if, for example, you
want to replace all fossil fuels, oil and gas,
with hydrogen, you have to be able to
calculate somehow how much
green electricity we need, how do we have to
increase the amount and by what factor and I
find that
really very interesting in this context and I would be there
I would be grateful if you
could give a number for the efficiency,
yes you often hear 80% efficiency for
efficiency for electrolysis
for that is then
screwed to product so hydrogen
is here if you put in a megawatt
you get 800 kilowatts out of it, which is
a more interesting number for us  would
probably be how it works in this
power plant in Prenzlau.
Unfortunately I don't have the numbers, but I have to
find out for the future. I hope
they are publicly accessible. How
efficiently can this be done because
that's one thing, the whole thing in the laboratory
and in
To produce it on a small scale is a different matter to
do it in a real power plant
and still be efficient.
Unfortunately, these values ​​are usually
a bit lower,
so I
think in
pilot and research I would say around
80% and again and again  a
bit on details for this
for the power plant there at the window really
look again and hope this data
is then accessible
[music] [
music]
this is an important point so that we
can store some
basic energy produced by the
water-electric but that
is  for the topic of water, green
hydrogen, that's an important aspect and
I'm a bit,
so if I understood that correctly,
a very important point that I did
n't address is where does
the water come from that you
want to store, ideally you would
n't put it in the  Water gaps and
no drinking water because you
have to drink and the supply of drinking water was
also one of the goals of the UN, so you
shouldn't influence each other.
Ideally you would
split water that is not
for drinking or otherwise usable, for
example sea water or wastewater
are there also technologies there was
an artificial breakthrough I think
you would hopefully see that in
the next few weeks
I think two 240 kilojoules
per and they can't change that
is always said
they have to invest this energy
if they can  a bit with this
effect scratch to play all the game
but to split a watch of water by water
electrolysis you need I
had students that is given as a management office
this task for example
that is that costs energy yes
quality of water is also we
need a good one
okay is when how can one develop the
chemical
[music]
to split a well of water
they need 400 240 or 41 kilos of Joel
just once of hydrogen it costs too
much energy that it doesn't
change
Efficiency is usable energy divided
by total energy
and yes  you always need energy but
you can use 100% of the energy you need
and then you would be 100%
efficient of course you don't achieve that
but you do
n't quite understand the argument
so
yes I have
a question here
about the perspectives on CO2 so to speak
the extraction, i.e. the artificial
photosynthesis,
how do you estimate what the
time horizons are because there
this problem of
the efficiency would be reduced by a lot on the one hand with
electrolysis and then also with
storage,
so to speak we wouldn't have it
The problem is very strong: what
materials do I have to
use for the electrode and what are
the prospects for artificial
photosynthesis? Yes, as I said, the colleague
here has it. Yes, we have already
developed a prototype for it and
others have already developed it
prototypasis
the dream and the goal is to produce more efficiently by
combining the individual parts in a
kind of technical plant,
but the reality is
that you also
have to solve a lot of other problems when you
do things together and that
it is probably easier at the time
Maybe the colleague can
contradict but simply connect an already
optimized electrolysis and an already
optimized TV or wind power plant
together and
generate that, but I think in the future
we should
put in more effort to produce it in an integrated manner and then
more efficiently.
That's a bit difficult to estimate,
but we're here  You can also say it will take longer, but
you can be wrong because
these photos are System 2, until you
know there are about a
million atoms and until you know where every
single atom is located, that's at the
specialist conference I was at
take five to ten years and the
next year you already knew it
if you never know it, we hope for
a breakthrough Science
doesn't work linearly Most of the time it doesn't work
Science works so you put in an
incredible amount of effort and
improve a little and at some point
you have a big idea  and there
is a leap and whether this leap
will come in 20 years, hopefully it
will happen in the past. It's
difficult to say. I wanted to
confirm it again.
This morning we had our event on
future research and mega trends, which
was now a little more
application-oriented, perhaps we can
You can say a little more about the
application, so hydrogen is particularly
interesting for the steel industry and the cement industry and
the
storage of hydrogen is really important. I answered
my short question
about the drives so we probably won't use it as a car
Driving with hydrogen cars there are
a whole series of disadvantages: the
low efficiency and the few
filling stations. There will be no
investments in that direction. The
really big investments come from
the steel and cement industries, i.e.
from the industry and that's where you
actually start  on
research and that is also
difficult to quantify costs now, how much does it
cost today? I remember
the discussion. I have always been a
big fan of renewable
energies. 20 years ago I
discussed it with people and they
always said that  You can't
pay for it, it's all far too expensive,
now the storm electricity from
renewable energies is clearly the
cheapest and that's shifting,
radical shifts can
take place and of course it's
almost impossible for you to estimate.
People want to have promises that
you can  never give you can only
promise that you will work incredibly hard with your
colleagues
just as you
said no but there will be breakthroughs
I am very very confident of that
yes and yes steel industry so
hydrogen embrittles steel so
steel also makes you worse than before
I think that's also a
very big issue, especially if you
want to store hydrogen in steel pressure vessels, which are supposed to
last a very long time and or
have to be routed through pipelines of some kind,
so they already provide energy as a good replacement
for
natural gas  they are also very keen on
inquiries,
yes, I
think, thanks for the tip, yes, that will
probably also be a very large
customer in the future. I wanted to
ask another question about the
geographical conditions as you
showed earlier, the
possibilities for renewable energy
production in the global  South is significantly
larger in time, last week there was a
very big article that, with the
mediation of the federal government, an
extremely large hydrogen production
is to take place in the south of Namibia with more
water desalination and which somehow
uses four times as much electricity
as Namibia itself uses in the year, as can be
seen realistically  You have this large
production of water in development in such
an emerging country and what is there?
The main challenge is it is also
mainly the price and if so
which elements are transport or or
production or are there also
technical capacities that
may be challenges
so hydrogen can be  Certainly
due to
solar radiation, the
global south produces much more cheaply, of course
investments are needed there first, there are also
alternatives to the desalination of
seawater and I have
already mentioned this point to you, ideally
especially in countries that don't
have that much drinking water, that would be an absolutely
terrible idea  To convert their remaining
drinking water into our fuel
and thus take it away,
in this respect you should
use water that would otherwise have no use there,
even if it then
has additional costs in the treatment that you
still have to take into account. As I said, there is
also newer research  Don't
say too much about it, but
hopefully it will
be in the news soon that there are
new technologies to make
more water or wastewater
usable, for example, but that you have to put so much
energy into it
and yes, well then there is  Of
course, this also creates further
transport costs, perhaps a
bit of dependence on
other countries again.
Personally, I am a big fan
of a decentralized
energy supply, but the way the
course is currently set, it is more in the
direction of
highly efficient production in the
global south and imports, perhaps
hopefully not  completely import but
at least
additional import and then to cover further needs
are there actually usage concepts for
the resulting oxygen now in
hydrogen production or will it
now evaporate into the atmosphere
very good question
no particularly well-
founded knowledge about what
exactly happens to it I'm afraid it's
cheaper to simply let it out
To store the atmosphere as the pressure bottles
and as a hydrogen master,
high-purity hydrogen and
high-purity oxygen are also produced, which
we use in our research, for example,
but perhaps
unfortunately there is no information about this, which is a
bit far away from my research topic
of electrical catalyst materials,
but oxygen itself is also one  Guest
asked that in the industry that
I hope that it is cheap enough that it can
then be sold on.
Yes, I would like to go back to perhaps at the
beginning of your lecture
you presented a few figures for the
energy consumption of 2300 terawatts per year
and you also have  When we say how much electricity
we currently produce from renewable energies,
it is 100 terawatts per
year,
hundreds of watt hours, which means that if
we
want to switch all energy consumption to
hydrogen and no longer to fossil
fuels, we would have to increase the proportion
of renewable energy  Increase factor 23,
which means we have to produce 23 times
more green electricity than we
currently do and that is still assuming
we have an efficiency of 1.0
if we still have a loss in
storage and and and and then
we arrive at numbers that we have 50  times
maybe a hundred times and
I don't think that's entirely realistic.
How do you see that? I
'm not aware of any studies for Germany, just off the
top of my head, but look it up again as I
probably didn't do my homework. Globally,
I had this study at the end
quoted here and they come
to the conclusion that it is possible to
switch to 100% hydrogen globally, that is because there are
enough options for installing it.
The
question is in
doubt as to whether there is enough free space
for
photovoltaics, but there is an incredible amount of
space on roofs, for example
Pilot projects
to install photovoltaics under streets have not yet been used,
so I think
we have more than enough area that is
not being used that could be used for this purpose,
at least for solar for
wind. I think that is
often very difficult, at least in the countryside
I still have great potential for
wind energy,
as I said, that's in Germany, so
I don't have a study that I
can accept. I think
we have enough space on roofs
somewhere else,
so if I can say something very briefly about it,
it's not about that
Switching the energy supply to 100% hydrogen is a
small component in
a larger system and if we
electrify, for example, then
many more processes will
run on electricity than they do now and that is
simply much more efficient than
combustion processors, for example and
then  I think we can also
increase efficiency in many
industrial areas so
that in the end we may not
need quite as much energy as we do now
and it's not about replacing everything
we need today in terms of fossil resources
one-to-one with hydrogen
It certainly won't
work like that because hydrogen
is relatively valuable and necessary in the long term for some very valuable
uses, for example, as wonderful
also said, as a raw material for the
company industry for perhaps certain
plastics industries and perhaps for
special transport applications, for
example for a somewhat more sustainable
aviation fuel but it  It won't
be the case that we will use hydrogen like gasoline,
I don't think so,
no further questions, we'll put it together in
time,
okay, then thank you very much for your interest
and yes
[applause]